For this problem, x would equal positive 1. Nice effort if you got this one
correct. To start solving this equation, we want to isolate the radical on one
side, so we need to get rid of the subtraction of 1 here. We add 1 to both
sides of the equation to get the 4th root of 3x minus 2 equals 1. We want to
undo this 4th root. So we raise both sides of the equation to the 4th power.
This leaves us with 3x minus 2 on the left, and 1 to the 4th, or just 1 on the
right. We add 2 to both sides of the equation to get 3x equals positive 3. And
finally, to get x by itself, we divide by the coefficient 3 to get x equals 1.
To be sure this is correct, we check this in the original equation. We
substitute x with the value of positive 1, and then try and check. Here, we'll
get a 4th root, a positive 1. And we know the 4th root of 1 is just 1. Then we
subtract to get 0 equals 0. So yes, this answer checks, which means this is our
solution.